[Musique]
les
angers quand d'aventuré zapper
audi 789 la révolution une époque de
grands changements et le grand homme qui
ont été raccourcis skis rice et thomas
vont garder leur tête mais j'espère bien
je me suis attaché à eux et j'espère
qu'ils vont finir ensemble
ah oui c'est mon côté romantique sinon
c'est bizarre vous m'avez toujours pas
mis cinq étoiles ça doit être un béni
oui oui c'est un bug
ouais vous savez moi aussi je peux vous
noté alors cette attention
mais comment il met des étoiles win a
pris sa guitare il faut trouver les
robots vraiment idées de merde vous êtes
des révolutionnaires des sans-culottes
comme on nous appelle
c'est parce que tu crois où les appelle
les sans culottes parce qu'à l'époque
les culottes étaient des pantalons de
riches c'est tout et ne croyais pas mes
gars mais c'est ma drogue je vous crois
pas que tout ça et continuer votre
évolution vous remettez votre compte en
actions
mais la révolution c'est fini ma ptite
dame on arrête ses conneries et on
rentre à la maison et puis la monarchie
c'est pas si mal en fait notre homme
était vraiment votre pantalon là je vous
regarde et pourquoi vous arrêter la
révolution parce que nous on a des
fourches et eux ils ont installé sur la
bastille un énorme canon qui lance pas
des boulets mais des rayons rouges qui
tue tout le monde
voilà pourquoi voit que ça pont d'ouilly
ça me perturbe encore un canon laser
ça c'est du cadet 29 tout craché
l'atom regarde c'est la prison de la
bastille mais ouvre les yeux bon sens
ils ont relu leurs pantalons oui ils
sont même partis allant là bas mais
qu'est ce qu'il fait lui
là c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent pas gagner
contre ça cadets 29 d'annuler la
révolution mais pourquoi tu poses la
question à votre tu me demande à moi
parce que je dois tout vous un truc tu
gardes pour toi j'ai pas très féru
d'histoire rabat merci j'avais compris
l'importance et trouver un moyen de se
débarrasser de ce canon laser
tu vois le truc qui sort du canon qui
descend dans les égouts le conte câble
là moi je dis on suit ce truc et on voit
où il nous mène
j'ai eu de la merde encore bon ok c'est
quoi non non non c'est un bon plan
thomas non c'est juste que je suis pas
habitué
[Musique]
rien gros chat là au bout du câble un
générateur
ça doit être ça qui alimente le canon il
ne reste plus qu à débrancher la prise
la prise de la bastille non mais quand
les gens rient moi je ris c'est plus
simple pour tout le monde
dmanche générateurs
[Musique]
se raconter
c'était super facile ou alors c'est un
piège ou alors on est devenue trop forte
et non
piège elliott bonjour nous avons conçu
ce piège autour d'une bonne blague
d'humains la prise électrique de la
bastille à aa la prise électrique
novosti j'ai compris bon courage à les
liens du sang d'argent on s'y attendait
bon courage
tiens et révolutionnaire
vous êtes l'heure où la révolution a
repris c'est pas la peine de nous
remercier
il pourrait quand même le faire en
mettant leurs pantalons ça a pris
tellement vite qu'on appelle d'autres se
rhabiller avec ronin minutes
vraiment la révolution peut attendre
achoui du coup maintenant on est
regonflé à bloc
du coup les riches qui arrivent sur les
habitats monarchie
ah bon bah amusez vous bien
sans vouloir vous offenser vous avez
l'air un peu rude c'est vrai ça avait
l'air un peu riche où ces gens retirent
annonce était gentil non non on n'est
pas riche pour ni pauvre robin qu'au
bout non moi j'ai un si petit toit 3
vous le tuer alors on a un test en trois
étapes pour savoir si vous êtes riche ou
pauvre est numéro 1 vous sentez pas le
cas à vous avez perdu mais c'est très
chaud ça peut s'arranger test numéro 2
ça vient pas ouvrir la bouche est fait à
dans chacun essaie encore perdu mais
enfin tu est numéro trois quel est votre
morceau de viande préférée soit bon ou
peut-être cochon le petit cochon bon vin
ce concert duo lefranc vous on voulait
divorcer bon sens il perdu aussi la
bonne réponse était c'est quoi la viande
parce que moi je mange des patates
vous êtes des riches on va vous déjà
buté
[Applaudissements]
je crois que j'ai bon hôte est numéro 1
mais très révolutionnaire
voici une dizaine de riches qui
soutiennent la monarchie lisible et ce
peuple c'est gentil mais vous étiez
j'ose espérer se diffuser mois vous
pouvez vous décider plus vite
il y en a qui attendent derrière allait
installer vous ici sur la planche with
vous faites votre travail
[Musique]
telle était sa polémique elle encore
couler
au nom de quoi le lapin ou va signer
lundi son live réclamant déjà plus de
tête durant ces mois montée sur cette
planche c'est un drôle de jeu thomas
mais déjà mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
commentait devenu gourou ça c'est une
longue histoire à raconter mon histoire
où je vous en parle tous
la dernière fois qu'on t'a vu tu étais
augmentait oui dans cette contrée
lointaine et mystérieuse qu'on n'appelle
jamais vraiment faim est là mais des
amis on est arrivés dans un véritable
paradis où la nourriture est servie à
foison duras poison on appelle ce lieu
le fleuve qui un tel lieu ne peut
exister auto s'il existe j'ai mangé de
tout des haricots des pas me frites
j'ai même pris en dessert de la compote
de pommes
[Applaudissements]
oui bon et après après le docteur six
mois a reçu un bout de papier ça
s'appelle l'addition il m'a dit ousmane
a buzzé aux toilettes et il n'est jamais
revenu
ah ouais c'est bien mais ça comme je
pouvais pas payer j'ai du travail en
cuisine pour rembourser ma dette mais
plus travailler plus j'avais faim et
plus j'avais faim plus manger et donc je
devais encore plus travailler ça
s'appelle le capitaliste
à
oui un piège démoniaque
j'ai continué à travailler pendant des
mois et des mois
et puis je me suis louer un petit studio
c'était pas si cher il venait d'ouvrir
la gare rer
et comme votre père n'est pas revenu
j'ai décidé de passer le permis b ou la
muse talent permis je suis devenu
manager chez flunch je me suis marié
encore j'ai divorcé c'était ma première
fois d'emballement j'abandonne mes
femmes sur une île et un jour le
professeur est revenu il était vraiment
aller aux toilettes mais il a préféré
aller faire ses besoins chez lui dans le
futur parce qu'il est géré ma femme ou
un truc comme ça
ils m'avaient pas oublié il s'était
seulement trompé dans la date de retour
de quelques années ah oui c'est bien lui
sauf pour s'excuser
il m'a proposé de me déposer dans
n'importe quelle époque et n'importe
quel lieu pour que je refasse pas vie je
lui ai dit tout sauf melun et si
possible un endroit où on peut couper
des têtes
alors elle m'a déposé ici et si devenu
bourreau le meilleur métier du monde
je suis content pour toi mais du coup tu
vas pas nous couper la tête
vous savez couper des têtes du matin
jusqu'au soir
[Musique]
pour faire ça mais des amis à leur
mission est terminée
l'appât qui parle ma sécu ce grand barbu
à te voilà temps on est tellement
contentes de revoir iris qu'est ce que
tu voulais me dire en fait au moment où
j'allais mourir 1 aujourd'hui je sais
plus mais si tu as dit jon et après avis
bas je te jette je sais c'est une
expression dans le futur tout le monde
dit ça ça veut dire oh la la il fait bon
mais il ya une petite brise
non personne ne du sang bon on peut y
aller maintenant laisse moi deviner
petit lapin et une nouvelle époque où il
faut empêcher le temps d'être modifiées
exactement la buse tu veux venir avec
nous ça dépend vous allez à melun non
oh là là tu aimes plaisir de retrouver
la buse aaa
le personnage préféré de l'épopée
temporel selon un sondage ipsos réalisé
sur mille personnes en france
métropolitaine
maintenant ils ont toutes leurs chances
d'arrêter les robots de casser le temps
un bon coup de hache dans la gueule ça
cale tout le monde à la semaine
prochaine vous venez d'écouter le
septième épisode de l'épopée temporel
merci beaucoup à la semaine prochaine
pour la suite